vous allez bien moi bof on m'a volé mon
ordinateur
en gros je rentrais du boulot et
chevalet dans une brasserie avec des
potes
j'ai pas eu le temps de rentrer chez moi
pour déposer mon ordinateur donc j'avais
mon ordinateur dans mon sac à mes pieds
un couple s'est installé derrière moi
ils ont déplacé mon sac derrière mon
siège ils ont pris mon ordinateur et ils
sont partis avant d'avoir consommé au
moment où j'ai compris qu'on m'avait
volé mon ordinateur avec toute ma vie
dedans ge
j'ai bugué non mais il est où
de quoi tu parles voilà j'ai buggé comme
ça pendant à peu près cinq minutes
peut-être ne redoutez là non or le
premier truc que j'ai fait c'est aller
dans le commissariat le plus proche
et dans ma tête ça allait se passer
comme ça on m'a volé mon ordinateur quoi
vous ça dans une brasserie
là bas un couple installé derrière vous
un ordinateur qui disparaît comment
savez vous je reconnais ce mode
opératoire le voleur a connu des forces
de police monté dans cette voiture
on va le coincer mais non non ça s'est
passé comme ça on a volé mon ordinateur
d'accord il va falloir attendre une
heure monsieur à
asseyez-vous
[Musique]
j'ai volé à l'ordinateur
[Applaudissements]
hop là alors le bon coin
[Musique]
au bout d'une heure d'attenté à mon tour
et là et donc voilà toute l'histoire
[Musique]
voilà bonne journée alors je savais
qu'on allait pas retrouvé mon ordinateur
comme ça
une feuille quoi si j'étais toi je ne
leur ai pas cet ordinateur
sinon on va me donner une feuille mon
dieu mais je n'en suis pas resté à comme
mon ordinateur était de la marque apple
j'ai pu utiliser la fonction localiser
qui te permet de faire deux choses si le
voleur se connecte à internet avec mon
ordinateur je peux soit localisé savoir
où il est mais il peut faire ce qu'il
veut avec mon ordinateur pas il a une
chaîne youtube supprimer faut bien un
petit café moi soit je peut verrouiller
l'ordinateur mais je sais pas où il est
j'ai pris la deuxième option par
sécurité mais une page facebook aussi je
n'aime pas les noirs
le plus fort c'est qu'avec cette option
on peut même écrire un message qui va
s'afficher sur l'ordinateur volé la
joule 10 de tous de tous les messages
qui peuvent exister sur la planète terre
en termes de dissuasion de ce que vous
voulez
j'ai choisi le vol c'est mal
comme si le voleur allait se dire voler
ses mots bonjour je vous rend votre
ordinateur
parce que c'est mal de voler merci
maintenant je vais faire du bénévolat
du coup j'ai reçu un mail d'apple qui
m'explique que le voleur a effectivement
tenté de se connecter mais que
l'ordinateur c'est bien verrouillé et
faites moi plaisir
faites attention à vos affaires ah oui
je suis une petite surprise pour vous
c'est mon téléphone